alright alright alright no one does that
anymore everyone does no one know
something and this is why you don't have
a date I'm Kaitlin an intuitive upon and
we are undateable we both didn't have
dates for Valentine's Day and we figured
that we put our heads together and kind
of give you a date for my selection and
you give me a different year selection
like that to make good I'm gonna tell
you what I want in my dick okay one I
want him to be a gentleman
alright ladies because we're not taking
anything not in 2020 I do have a height
requirement
this is grace grace is the highness
I just you gotta be at least at least
five ten I'm too like my man like a girl
no love you know but like I like them to
be a little like muscular in like a
little big cuz I do I'm small I'm C so
like I kind of like a guy to just like
to like to hug me let me what would you
like in your ideal date I'm looking for
a woman with someone who takes pride in
herself loves her parents oh wow really
bad I understand is right hey a woman
with a beautiful personality as well as
big asset would also be preferred and a
woman who doesn't mind a have fun I like
that she's a big asset now what are some
deal-breakers like what game breaker
yeah I'm open to understanding like
other beliefs but if you do not believe
in a higher power and we can't discuss
that then I don't I don't think it could
work
what happened if the higher power that
they believe in is the Sun from the
Teletubbies that is it's a higher power
it's literally a higher power so we get
its but so far good smile can get you
you don't watch that we are actually dr.
Turner go into one of the best Mexican
restaurant in the city javelina Molina
yes they're nachos and they have to
queso dibs let's just put that out there
they have a so dips it's really good get
away so okay we need to make a bet
because that a monthly metro car was
good that is a good base I'm not gonna
lie cuz you know that a multi ffensive
outset among New York all right fine
monthly MetroCard on that now is for you
to decide
alright say that hey remember this face
and how confident it is okay yeah I'm a
win it's gonna be it's gonna be me okay
[Music]
my girl her name is Flo and she
definitely goes with the flow she's
literally laid-back bubbly personality
she is a photographer and she's not just
any photographer okay she is a
photographer whose work with cardi B
okay it's crazy that I'm really good at
fighting yeah I'm not a weird way but
just like your dream search isn't
something right well I think I've gotten
very comfortable with that and like
actually knowing that right is it's a
different teal but that's how it should
be yeah I picked one of my good friends
his name is Bo Lauren and by Lauren is a
comedian and a comedic actor I don't
know what he does you know day by day
could drive a cab he could do people's
feet I don't know but I know he's a
funny guy I did tell him to wear
something a little revealing so maybe we
could see a little bit of pectorals you
know she likes breasts and he hasn't did
you bring it in the caliber in case I
need that you know fire one oh but what
are you expecting from the state like
what do you think he's gonna look like
you think you good I think I'm good I'm
not good with women but we're gonna see
what happened yeah sure I'm so much
[Music]
all right let's go let's go yes good
you're not my blazer today okay I don't
know what you look like
ah but I said I'm coming to impress you
look a little summary like what was the
value or important but I'm getting
summer down here and then winter up here
oh yeah true that is true but this is
mainly because I don't have a property
haircuts I mean I didn't have the time
and the shirt I don't know like it's
like so we're not contagious is what you
say yeah okay all right cool just making
sure I don't make sure you know sure do
the mother Macarena is that it isn't
that a dirt you seem like you'd be
traditional but I'm gonna have you do
the jalapeno I feel like you need some
spice in your life so I'll do the
are the tacos how would a veggie fingers
they're really good let's go with that
let's do african-american thank you
oh thanks you didn't get stroke excuse
me can we get a straw for the for the
gentleman he needs a straw Musa I mean
you know I just wanted I just don't see
why you got one because ladies Elise
this is a day of equality or equality
rather what did they call me equal
rights I cannot so what do you do I'm
not really give me like how many bucks
you know what's interesting I'll just
stand up like 14 minutes 21 yeah yeah
yeah that's why I started they're not
just not being funny and you know with
people when people like put the arm
around you and go what he tried me
so tell me like what do you mean so
you're not laid back here more I am
animated really yes Wow Wow I have never
met a black figure oh yeah that was
kinda nice too I got to I saw that in I
Tanya because I that was a good movie it
was a good movie oh wow
I thought sizzling sounds like Jada's
thank you that's hit me really need to
catch up
oh my gosh ah dang look laughs this is
an unfair racer yeah mmm eat your head
up I mean you shouldn't be getting no
brain freezes with the brain you got the
beep anymore huh my dome warm as the
dome heat it looked like the popcorn you
know wonder number one on the stovetop
thank you
what's like a holy mecca of skating like
where the skate is going be like yeah
I'm here I'm here son what's good does
not sound like Rucker Park at all so why
are you single
maybe this is why you're single cuz like
this where you can't tell like it's like
is he being sarcastic right now or I
don't think so
so is dating feasible for you to like at
the moment I think I'm gonna happen
enough to a person yeah really I mean
like any of us are right right I do
think I kind of have this sort of like
semi toxic way to my taxes I think I'm
definitely someone who's like not really
it's like the nice guy I'm probably more
attracted to like like I know somebody
with a record I don't know how to wrap
up women asked men from numbers now I
love this had to ask a guy friend's
number
why don't approach men you don't
approach I don't you already hit he not
approach thing I would not ask me in a
bad way
I just don't do that this is 1912 and
it's like yeah forbidden I feel like the
man is usually the one who makes the
move if I have to do it that means the
man isn't as interested in me as I am in
him and I don't want that again
I wouldn't ask for you
it's just nothing I'm sorry what asked
for my number but I would avoid ordering
my drinks this is very fine yes I really
enjoyed myself yes oh thank you yeah all
right it was nice meeting you
same here I enjoy it I had I enjoyed our
little little drink here you would have
really good conversation good banter I
like it yeah thank you
I like your head and I like these chips
okay so she just finished her day it
tell me how you thought about the date
oh cool that's cool he was nice what
energy fun they would think about it
overall then category on a scaler was
his head on conversation definitely the
tunnel conversation
yeah they asked a lot of the question I
think that like we both somewhat talkers
wonder ken would you give like the
conversation overall conversation like
eight did you find him attractive like
on a scale of one to ten she was ugly
handsome like he also had a really good
skin I was like wow that's a really good
would you say that she was attractive
yes was attractive yes he had the
eyeliner going like cat eyes how good of
a match do you think you guys are I
believe I definitely be friends with him
that's why our be friends with him so I
think that like what we were talking
like this personality was definitely
there but I feel like the attraction
wasn't so there so that's why the match
didn't fare make sense well of a friend
like I was
it was enough to start the engine like
you know that I guess I don't really
know you're just as much yeah maybe I
made on Sam I can see why you would
think because I'm like both of you guys
are like funny and like energetic and
outgoing yeah that you guys would hit it
off like cuz you said personality it
seems like from the average that you
would do a second date
[Music]
we'd a winning team we just had our
blind dates what you think well first of
all okay leans drunk so that's one thing
I wouldn't say I'm drunk I'm just here
addictive Mondego actually I hate to say
it it went well it went well but he's
but he's not my type he didn't give me
fanny flutters like he didn't give me
let's move our hands up a little Danny
yeah no he didn't give me fanny [ __ ] it
was I liked the conversation you know
but I didn't get any serious answers
from him it was very sarcastic it was
more so like yeah you know like I was I
was born out the womb a brolic man what
is that all right first of all did you
not say you like strong men yes okay
did you ask for a specific strong voice
tell me about your date cuz I feel like
you guys probably hit it off and a night
wasn't there but we talked about a lot
of things you know about past
relationships we talked about life we
talked about career we talked about
adventures it was a really nice day
farther than that guy yeah well I'm a
different type of breed he's nothing
saying
you see these fans the different type of
breed right here he's a tweed she was a
really really nice person very very nice
person just not for me through this
world I feel like we both felt the same
way about our dates I don't think we
both if he's talking about he won but I
honestly think we it's a tie I feel like
I know exactly what I'm looking for my
significant other and I don't think that
he he checked all my boxes
is he funny yes carry a conversation yes
is he like fit yes yes okay okay okay
like I like them to be a little like
muscular I do want somebody who can have
a conversation it's like one thank you
take it out the weak brain combo let's
go you might be a New Yorker after all
what does it smell like Meek Mill bridge
mmm for a month okay
okay lean look you're a good sport I
wish you the best of luck and I'm
getting every step in a way with you or
you go to the expert yeah yeah I'm out
of a love connection but I didn't really
provide I tried I got you everything you
wanted in on paper